[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
sorry I'm just a bit late trying to get
started here this morning
on a Thursday you know how it goes with
me you know how it is on Thursdays I'm
mayor
may not have
partaked last night you know what I'm
talking about Jagermeister [__]
oh boy guilty guilty four out of five
guilty of seditious conspiracy this is
the second seditious uh trial in
conspiracy to commit sedition
hmm well
wouldn't you know it they're guilty of
trying to overthrow our government
duh no [__] Sherlock
could have seen that one coming I mean
how many more phrases do I need to
explain this to you
of course the [__] proud boys are
guilty of seditious conspiracy they
conspired with the Cheeto dust q and
honor
that's what is so significant about this
if you were following the trial at all
they were really trying to blame the
planning of the Sedition on Donald Trump
the proud boys
so
now we have a situation where not only
are The Oath Keepers with Stuart Rose at
the helm guilty of seditious conspiracy
also the other group that they conspired
with I don't know maybe we'll play this
tape today
again of uh Enrique tario and Stuart
Rhodes conspiring in a parking garage
the night before January 6 when Enrique
tario was not supposed to be in
Washington DC and let me tell you
something about this seditious
conspiracy trial
um that really the person that is held
guilty here and that is significant is
Enrico tario and the reason why is
because Taria was not in Washington DC
during the Insurrection and he has been
found guilty by a jury of his peers of
seditious conspiracy
this is this is huge
this is a big deal and the reason why
this is a big deal
is because Grandpa Poopypants wasn't at
the Capitol either
he was sitting in the White House
cheering it on
cheering on the action of the plan of
The Proud boys and The Oath Keepers
and the violent insurrectionist and not
only that the insurrectionist in
Congress
them trying to overturn our vote our
government
and if you don't think Jack Smith has
been paying attention to what the proud
boys trial and the in the guilty verdict
that has brought today on the first
count of seditious conspiracy where four
out of the five
have been found guilty guilty guilty
guilty of sedition
some of them not even at the Capitol
I don't think that that detail is lost
on Jack Smith
as we March towards
probably in our future a seditious
conspiracy trial of Donald Trump and his
allies who were trying to overthrow our
government
vis-a-vis the proud boys vis-a-vis The
Oath Keepers vis-a-vis the the fake
State elector scheme
and I believe that there's probably no
one better to do it than Jack Smith
democracy's coming for your ass
oh I'm happy this morning I'm really
happy this morning I don't know uh maybe
it's just those those conspiracy charges
that make me so happy
but you don't think I could get pissed
come on now of course I can get pissed
you heard about Harlan Hitler right
you know who Harlan Hitler is this guy
man he knows how to buy him some judges
oh [__] me let me tell you something
there is no better person to buy a bunch
of right wing
[__] fascist judges than Harlan
Hitler
holy [__] and you know what they'll pay
for elitist private education in this
[__] funniest [__] uh some people are
giving me [__] because I'm calling him
Harlan Hitler not Crow listen I could
call him whatever the [__] I want
if he gets to pay a Supreme Court
Justice child to go to some Elite ass
private school pay for him to be on
yachts
pay for him to go lavish vacations all
around the world give him money for a
house and make his mother live rent free
I I get the right of the right First
Amendment right to call him whatever the
[__] I want
[__] him and Clarence Thomas [__] him
[__] em [__] em [__] em
you're gonna pay you're gonna pay for
for a supreme court justices
child to go to some elite private school
and then you're gonna call Democrats
middle class working Americans who just
don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill they want a decent [__]
wage they don't want to have to [__]
borrow their entire lives to get an
education or a [__] mortgage
they want their kids to go to school you
[__] you [__] you
[__] you thought I wasn't gonna
get pissed you [__]
lecturing us on Elites get the [__] out
of here with that [__] I'm sick and
tired of the right wing and the
conservative the Nazis they're [__]
Nazis calling us the elite
you brain dead [__]
I'm sick of that [__] I'm tired of it I
am [__] sick and tired of the right
calling the left Elites you are you are
some dumb sons of [__] if you think
that the left somehow is from all the
East Coast goes to all the private
[__] schools you sons of
[__] are paying for Supreme Court
Justices kids to go to elite elite
private schools
and you're not reporting it number one
say you're hiding it
and you're gonna call us the [__]
Elites get the [__] out of here with
that [__] man we just don't want you to
[__] be telling people who they can
love we don't want you to be banning
women's [__] Health Care stay the
[__] out of our lives
and stop doing it under the guise of
your [__] hatred and you thinking
that Democrats and Liberals are somehow
elitist [__] you
go to hell with that [__] and honestly I
don't think this is the worst thing that
we're gonna find out about Harlan Hitler
paying for judges and giving them money
because that's what he's doing he's
giving them [__] money
when you're paying for some [__]
judges kid to go to some school
somewhere you're giving them [__]
money
[__] you with this oh well
they do it too and that's and they did
that and oh my God you're just you're
just doing this because Clarence Thomas
is black get the [__] out of here he
ain't black
[__] you he ain't been black for a long
time
you think you you really believe that
Clarence Thomas has the same experience
as other people of color in this country
when Harlan Hitler is paying for lavish
vacations
Yachts Resorts buying his home and
letting his mother live there rent-free
I would I would almost guess
I would almost guess and I'm just some
crusty white cracker but I would guess
people of color would give you a [__]
what for when you say that the reason
why we're attacking Clarence Thomas
because he's a corrupt [__]
receiving corrupt dollars not reporting
it receiving income money from some
[__] in Texas who loves his
signed copy of mineconf I would imagine
I would imagine that they're like that's
not the reason why we're attacking him
is because he used to be black
[__] him [__] him and his [__] Q Anon
wife [__] him
and I I hope I hope Jack Smith is ass
deep in those [__] to be quite
honest with you I wouldn't be surprised
impeach that [__] impeach him
and every [__] like him I don't
give a [__] what party they are what
color they are if some [__] [__]
in Texas who who collects Hitler
memorabilia who's got a signed copy of
mine comp it's ramming money down their
[__] throats and buying those sons of
[__] get rid of them [__] them
it's time
it's time now right now is the time and
we can do it us the people the [__]
government [__] them
we got a lot of big races I know
everyone wants to make bones about the
presidential race but frankly folks
that's in the [__] sack now that's
done Ron DeSantis is not gonna run there
ain't anyone else that's going to level
any kind of competition against the
against the Republican Jesus the [__]
orange deity the Cheeto dust q and on or
Grandpa Poopypants ain't no [__] way
it's a cult cult cult and they're gonna
pick their cult leader that's just how
it's gonna be I've been telling this for
[__] months I've been trying to be
nice about it too yeah that's me trying
to be nice about it
you some of you [__] doubted me
you're like no no way I've seen this
[__] in January no way he ain't gonna
win no way Rhonda santis this Rhonda
said get the [__] out of here with the
Rhonda saying this [__] that guy's a
[__] weirdo
he couldn't work his way out of a wet
paper sack he just loves fascism and
there's in the fascist in Florida are on
the move
[__] out of here man
it is going to be Joe Biden versus
Donald Trump and Joe Biden is going to
kick his ass by more than 10 million
votes mark it down May 4th Thursday 12
17 8 12 17 p.m eastern time I'm a little
behind you know it's the Jagermeister
probably
um
mark it down Donald Trump will lose by
almost 10 million votes in the popular
vote and the states are going to swing
the exact same way
[__] them
the thing we have to concentrate on the
2024 race is more important races
than Donald Trump getting his [__]
ass waxed again we have to pay attention
to it don't get me wrong we're gonna
have to pay attention to it and we're
really gonna have to politicize the [__]
out of everything every [__] thing
I mean it's gonna be a heavy lift to get
to that 10 million but we're gonna do it
we are going to do it I'm telling you
him we're gonna [__] do it together
every day right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and all around the
world we are gonna do it together
to push this over the edge
but there's more important races
than just the presidential race we gotta
win back [__] the House of
Representatives I don't know if you
noticed this these [__] don't
know what the debt ceiling even is
I don't know if you I don't know if you
are paying attention to that or not
don't even know what the debt ceiling is
we have we have to we have to win some
of these Senate seats we do not have a
choice people
it is obvious to get the work done of
the people we have because the Senate is
[__] anyways I mean when you only got
two senators per state
and a state like [__] Alabama has the
same amount of senators as a state like
California well the odds are not in the
majority's favor
it instantly
when you have some dumb [__] like Tommy
tuberville
representing the same amount of
represent the same amount of votes
as as Feinstein in California
who isn't even on the floor and in her
committees yeah I'd I'd say we're
[__] starting behind anyways
so we have to work hard we're gonna have
to kick some [__] ass Ted Cruz needs
to go go go
and some [__] hate Ted Cruz but
it's still gonna be an uphill battle
even with that even with that slime ball
even with that [__] slime ball
we're gonna have to work our asses off
so get ready it's gonna be difficult
you're gonna have to engage in the [__]
out of your democracy because it ain't
just the federal races folks
I don't know if you've been paying
attention to what the [__] they're doing
in these goddamn States but I'm telling
you they're gonna keep coming for you as
much as they can wherever they can
they're coming for your Liberty they're
coming for your rights Women's Health
Care people's ability to to to [__]
identify the way they want to dress the
way they want
to love who they want to love they're
going to take they're gonna take away
your your [__] Liberty to read books
they're gonna take away your parental
consent Jesus Christ they want to make
sure some people can't even go in a
public bathroom are you paying attention
they're Nazis they're [__] Nazis
and there's one thing I know better than
anything else trust me on this I know
this
the fascist Kryptonite is loud noises
and when you couple loud noises with the
truth We will bury them
so when they're digging their political
grave
don't take the shovel out of their hand
hand them a [__] backhoe that's what
you do you goddamn right and frankly you
know I've been thinking about this CNN
thing this town hall with with Grandpa
poopy pants I've been thinking about a
lot and really honestly I mean I know
CNN's going to do a really shitty job of
holding him accountable at any [__]
level
but let me tell you something
the more that [__] talks the
more lunacy we show the American people
the worse off he is if you think for one
second that that some [__] is popular
I'm gonna show you a poll today out of
Tennessee and I don't normally show you
polls you know this but this poll is
[__] hilarious it's hilarious it's a
Twitter poll and it's from some [__]
Trump shill down in Tennessee
about guns and it's fan [__] tastic
and I'm gonna show it to you today I'm
going to show you this if I don't again
I don't normally show polls
we're gonna show one today because again
it's hilarious
and I'm gonna show you
that look Trump is not popular people
don't like that [__] even the
people voting for him don't like that
[__] he's a lunatic he's crazy
he doesn't make any [__] sense at all
he's a goddamn Coastal Elite
he's a silver spoon [__]
he lives in one of the biggest houses in
the entire country get the [__] out of
here he's for the Common Man
they don't like him yes but they still
vote for him it's called affiliation
folks that's where we need to draw this
wedge that's where we need to pound it
home
and get loud make sure our message and
our narrative is on point because it's
not just about him but it's about all
the down ballot races that are going to
be affected by his candidacy
that's how it works in elections and
yeah we're gonna get in the weeds over
the next year year and a half about how
elections are and how they work
and how we're going to politicize this
this is basically going to be a a
political science
experiment here on this show
and you are gonna come along for the
ride
because I'm not gonna stop being loud
I'm not gonna stop the fascist
Kryptonite they [__] hate it by the
way
and it's not just the fascists that hate
the way I do this
a lot of people on the left [__] hate
how I do this they [__] hate it
they hate that I oh Tony Tony doesn't
have data or polls on his show they know
he doesn't show he didn't back his his
rhetoric and his commentary up with data
and facts
get the [__] out of here I don't need a
bunch of facts to tell you that people
in this country do not want to go broke
because of a medical bill
what the [__] don't you get you think
you you honestly think who's going in
what bathroom is people's on people's
front of their mind no it is not
they want a decent [__] wage so they
can afford groceries they want a decent
[__] wage so they can afford a house
they want decent [__] wages so they
can afford to send their kids to school
without putting them in rags
they would love to pay for their kids
school lunch but they can't
they would love to have have the
benefits that come with employment so
they don't go broke because of a medical
bill they would love to have all those
things
they would love to be able to afford to
buy a car and then fix it when the
[__] gets broken
they would love they would there's
writers
right now that are striking listen to me
when I tell you this that are writers
that are striking I showed you a video
yesterday of CNN the CEO of Time Warner
makes 250 million dollars
250 million dollars a quarter of a
billion dollars a year those 10 000
writers are asking for the split of one
motherfucker's pay
their time is up
we're wise to it
and you're [__] your [__] stupid
ass distraction with culture wars Bud
Light Eminem's and children's genitalia
it's [__] weird it's weird at best
but we know it's all [__] the whole
[__] thing
the whole month in Missouri in Missouri
the governor listen to this listen to
hell [__] listen to the craziness
that trumpism and fascism this Maga
fascism has wrought on our [__]
country the governor of Missouri is
considering
to call a special session
are you following me
they're in session right now they're
going to end it and then he's going to
open up a whole new session
cost the state millions of dollars to
have this session
guess what the session's gonna be about
the special session transgender athletes
in Missouri
you stupid bastards
dare
in Mission Misha is Missouri's state
Association of athletes like High School
junior high athletes school athletes
public school athletes
it's their Regulatory Commission
in Misha I think there's three or four
in the entire state
they're going to hold a special session
in Missouri to discriminate against
three underage people
pluck your head out of your [__] ass
It's Time to Get Loud and be [__]
pissed off
and yell and scream I'm telling you it's
gonna work
I'm telling you I would not sit here
every day and do this if I didn't
believe that it was a strategy to save
our democracy I wouldn't
it will work
and the reason why I know it'll work
it's what the right has always done
they have the minority ideology in this
country and they still have huge power
grabs
because the left won't do what I'm doing
well I'm sick and [__] tired of it
and I know you are too
I know you're [__] tired of it I know
America is sick of this [__] we
shouldn't have to sit here and put up
with this stupid [__] trash we
shouldn't have to
we should be electing serious [__]
people to handle serious [__]
problems that the American people are
serious about and they want it dealt
with in serious [__] ways even if we
disagree
I know I disagree with plenty of people
on the left I don't give a [__] at this
point we're on the same team because
we're trying to save our democracy so we
can [__] compromise later on yeah
that's right
the left needs to all get on the same
[__] team and bat in the same
direction we're playing on the same
[__] team and yeah it may take
a while but one of these days we'll be
able to compromise with each other
because if you're not if you're not
paying attention I'm telling you
I'm telling you
the fascists are at the front door
they're knocking
but they're wearing their hoods and
they're wearing their swastikas they're
not [__] hiding it anymore we know
exactly who they are
and it's time
it's time we get loud it's time we use
our voice it's time we use our
microphones our megaphones it's time
that we use our ballot
save the democracy
four out of five proud boys
who conspired with the Cheeto dust cue
in honor
and The Oath Keepers
they said they did
were found guilty of seditious
conspiracy of trying to overthrow our
vote
you don't get too much of a threat to
democracy than that folks
and they did it with violence
they did it with lies
the big lie in fact
and let me give you another little
secret
the big lie about the 2020 election that
they're still [__] that they're still
propagating
the [__] about 2020 it's not the
biggest lie that they're telling
you want to know what the biggest lie is
that fascism trumpism and Trump himself
and all these Trump supporters are
popular they're [__] not
they may be in their little stupid
[__] bubble and they may get
Association votes
just outside their bubble
but we need to pop the [__] bubble
it's time
now is the time to get engaged in your
democracy and the one way you can do it
is listen to this show every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget to go to YouTube and subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast it's super
important you don't want to miss a
single day I mean you watch it live but
if you miss it live no no no no problem
you can listen to it on YouTube or you
can download it on Apple Spotify Google
it's free99 to download it this show
will always be free whether it's two
hours or three hours we're trying to go
to three hours it will always be free
for you to download
or to watch live and you can watch it
live on Twitch
twitch is another great place you can
watch it live the other thing about
twitch that is great if you're an Amazon
Prime subscriber if you're an Amazon
Prime usually you can link your Amazon
account to your Twitch account and you
can give us the one free subscription
that you get with your Prime account and
we get a couple bucks literally it
doesn't cost you a single nickel and we
get a couple bucks yeah I know it's five
dollars but then Amazon gives twitch
like half of it and then they take
another [__] fee so it's a couple
bucks but it doesn't cost you a thing it
doesn't cost us the thing it's an easy
way for us to get monetary support from
you without costing you a single nickel
more than you already paid for your
Amazon Prime account so don't forget to
link those two
and give us that subscription the other
place you can watch the show for free is
on Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account follow us at the Tony Michaels
at the Tony Michaels and also you're not
going to want to forget to follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod because
we're going to vote for bonehead of the
week this evening tomorrow is Friday and
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and we break it down every
single Friday in the second hour you'll
be able to vote on YouTube so don't
forget to subscribe there once again
everyone stick around
I got some clips to show you probably
there's plenty of [__] to go through
with Thomas and the proud boys and oh my
God it just doesn't end I I didn't get
to tell you about the Tucker Carlson
text messages yesterday where he thinks
white dudes fight a certain way and
non-white dudes fight another way or
something I don't know he's crazy he
wants people to get killed or something
he's out of his mind I'm gonna show you
that text there's some other [__] that
we forgot yesterday we just ran out of
[__] time so don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
years Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
foreign
Thursday
you know what that means
I had Jagermeister yesterday the [__]
that means everybody knows that oh God
damn
who I didn't have that much uh
Jagermeister though last night I don't
know three four shots you know it's
usually what I drink although last night
I did start with tequila I started with
a margarita
um maybe maybe uh Gabe will find that
funny I mean and you know I I'm gonna
tell on myself here a little bit because
um as much as everyone's like oh my God
oh my God are you drink Jagermeister
that's disgusting well I I here's the
thing when I when I drink
Margaritas the ones I like yeah you're
gonna think yeah you know whatever I
don't give a [__] I like the frozen
strawberry margaritas that's one I like
and and I like to have sugar around the
rim not [__] salt
I just I just don't that's the way I
want it I want that [__] I want
a [__] Margarita that's sweet
I'm not opposed to like lime you know
Margarita on the rocks with salt I'm not
opposed to it I mean I'll drink it
especially if someone's gotta pay for it
but I like the frozen strawberry
margaritas that's what I like now the
one the one thing uh Christina says I
have a sweet tooth which
um I I don't know if it's a sweet tooth
I just that's what I how I prefer it I
guess
the tequila I mean I'm not I'm not
saying I won't drink Straight Tequila
it's a [__] but I'll drink
Straight Tequila I just prefer it in
in a strawberry slushie because that's
that's what I think of right like when I
you know I feel like a [__] kid again
I'm drinking a [__] strawberry
slushie that's got some tequila in it
and I'm not saying that when I was a kid
I wasn't putting alcohol in my slushies
I'm not saying that or I ain't maybe I
am I don't know you [__] decide but
the point is is that yeah and I don't
want the salt and I love salt I [__]
love salt I [__] love it but I I I
want the sugar around the rim
is what I want
so that's how I order them
and you know you don't like it well [__]
you but that's you know and that's
really the only like um
you know sort of like uh I would call it
sweets you know kind of drink I don't
like wine I mean I'll drink it but I
don't really like it I mean I prefer
beer over wine
but I I don't like sweet drinks either
you know like a mixed cocktail or
something that's not my thing I'd rather
have a beer I I'm not opposed to like um
uh the the white claws there's a few of
them I don't like but they're not that
sweet you know the Seltzer Waters I know
Gabe Sanchez probably loves those
because they're carbonated water right
it's got alcohol on it like how perfect
is that and we're I'm I'm making fun of
him without him here but you know and it
happens and you can hate on me
but you know that's um
uh you know
Silly Wonka says you ought to learn how
Germans
drink Jaeger I I mean is there is there
something that they put it in
that they're that they're drinking I
mean I drink it a couple different ways
I'll I drink it straight that's normally
how I order it at the bar
um but my wife likes Jaeger too but she
like she doesn't like straight Yeager
she wants to do Jager Bombs which is the
Jaeger with the Red Bull or the uh
monster into the energy drink right in
in the stupid little cup with the shot
glass in the middle and then the the
rimmed glass
so you know how to drink those right
and I'll drink almost just about
anything anyone puts in front of me
almost anything
I I that's my preferred drug really I
mean let's just say it and I maybe I'm
telling on myself I don't know but I
don't you know I'm not again I'm not
gonna hide something
and political T says Tony uh you drink
it straight after a large meal yeah I've
heard that that that's actually the the
purpose of Jaeger is to like settle your
stomach right and really honestly like
that that's one of the reasons why I
like it is because normally you know you
go out to the bar you've had some food
to eat so you see you drink Jagermeister
and you know you don't feel like you're
gonna [__] puke later I mean unless
you drank too much [__] Jager like I
did on my birthday and then
you're definitely gonna [__] puke
but it's not it's not um
again it's just a it's just a preference
because I don't I don't like to drink
beer anymore as in just sit and drink
beer after beer after beer after beer
it's not my thing anymore it used to be
when I was younger but but I I don't
like to get totally [__] wasted you
know what I mean like there's you know
the drunk is a spectrum I guess you'd
say and I like to have you know a decent
buzz but I don't want to be so [__]
drunk that I'm blackout drunk like my
birthday that was the last time I got
blackout drunk in a long time and I'm
telling you it it didn't
you were here you I mean you were here
watching me I was still [__] drunk
yes the Thursday after my birthday I was
still wasted on air I I it took all
morning for me to try to get my [__]
straight so I can talk into the
microphone I did it though you gotta
admit I [__] did it I [__] pulled
it out I don't know how I I don't know
how I pulled it off not pulled it out I
pulled it out I didn't pull it out I
pulled it off
oh my God okay I've gone too far you
know what let's shoot the [__] while
we're here anyone got any questions why
not why were we waiting on Gabe Sanchez
yeah he had a few things to do this
morning so he's gonna be on the show I
believe but he just running a bit behind
um
anyone got any questions here we'll
we'll shoot the [__] if you got a
question uh throw it in the chat here uh
rather on YouTube Twitter or twitch or
actually Twitter if you put a question
on Twitter I can't see it so you're
gonna have to come over to Facebook
uh YouTube or twitch to get your
question in
um so do do I do I have
hey Tony do I have anything on Rudy
Giuliani what do you mean like evidence
I mean other than what there is I think
Rudy giuliani's in big [__]
trouble in Georgia
oh [__] I think Rudy giuliani's gonna
probably catch some of the highest
charges and and by highest I mean the
most the most amount like count wise
and he's gonna have some pretty big
charges to deal with
um he's kind of [__]
so uh ba Ware says when Will trump be
charged with sedition I mean it's gonna
if he's get if he gets charged with
sedition which I think he probably will
um based on what we're seeing out of
some of these trials and then some of
the evidence that's out in the public
from the January 6 elect committee but
if that's if there's worse evidence
behind that I think we will but I don't
think Jack Smith is going to rush to get
to a to an indictment from a grand jury
I think he's going to have you know his
eyes dotted in his T's crossed Jack
Smith If he if he goes to the grand jury
and asks the grand jury to indict Trump
on seditious conspiracy I would imagine
Jack Smith is going to make sure he can
slam dunk that [__] now I want
to be clear about this I want I want the
audience to understand this that even
though Jack Smith May indict him which
it'll probably be sometime this year
still probably this spring I think um
Fannie Willis may make a move on this
[__] before Jack Smith that's
unclear it's it's unclear exactly how
those cases overlap and the overlapping
of them could possibly affect which one
goes first if Georgia goes at all
because they're all part of the same
seditious selection conspiracy with the
fake electors [__] uh scheme so
but here's the thing is that the
disappointment in the electorate is
going to be this is that he's going to
be indicted on these charges but he's
not going to get to trial before the
election he won't go to trial in the New
York case the Georgia case or the
federal case I don't believe
I actually I believe that a judge will
not allow a candidate for president who
is clearly going to be the nominee of
the Republican party I don't think
they're going to allow these trials are
for these charges to go to trial before
the election I I really don't see that
happening
um I I just you know maybe it's it's not
that I don't have faith in the judges I
just don't see that they're going to do
that I don't think they are I don't
think they will do that
Maybe I'm Wrong
I rarely am if you think I'm wrong just
go back and listen to what I was saying
about Rhonda santis in February go
listen to it
just go listen to what I was saying
about Ron DeSantis in February like oh
yeah Tony knows a little he knows a
little bit about pile of dicks and
elections and how the electorate Works
he knows
I've been paying attention to it for
over [__] 20 years okay I've been
paying attention for a long time I I I'm
a two-time College Dropout but I was a
poli SCI major not that that means
anything it just means that I was
stunning Civics and how the [__] works
yeah it's boring that's and I'm an idiot
so I
I'm a [__] idiot so I quit school
twice
um but I think I think
um
when he will be will be sometime this
year but we're not going to see a trial
so don't don't get weird when he doesn't
get arrested
um that's that's what we want now that
it one other questions do we got here
man where's the rake merch oh yes that's
a great question it's a great question I
got the first final draft this morning
we're gonna have to make some changes to
it
um but um that draft I'm hoping this
afternoon we will get the changes made
from that draft so I'm hoping we will
have the rake merch in the store
tomorrow by the end of the day
um if not by the showtime tomorrow I
want to have that thing in the in the in
the store for you guys to look at
um everyone and today probably what I'll
do too if you're on patreon
um all you patreon members out there if
you're not you can go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and you can just hit the uh
the patreon link there at the top it'll
take you to the patreon page if you
become a patreon member
um you can see the first draft the black
and white version of the art and today
I'll probably put the version that I
have in there if I can't get the new
draft
so it goes through a process because we
have an artist and like we got to go
back and forth make some changes and
then go here and then go there and get
this part right get that part right
um because we you know I I mean I I'm
gonna ask you guys to spend some money
on the merch so I want it to be a cool
design right so we're spending time to
make sure it's exactly what what we want
but what we think will look good
um so
[Music]
um oh here we go uh Crystal asked a good
question Tony do you have any
predictions of CNN [__] show for the
town hall coming up so I I do have some
predictions
um I'm changing my mind a little bit on
it like I think it's a really stupid
idea for them to do it in the first
place but really honestly if they're
gonna do it
they might as well make him look like a
lunatic right I mean it's going to be
really easy to do to make him look like
a lunatic he [__] is one so but but
my my hesitancy with um saying yeah go
ahead [__] it just put him on the air
whenever you can however you can just to
show the whole country this guy's lost
his [__] mind like his marbles pack
their [__] and left like come on Harold
pack your [__] we're getting the hell
out of here this guy's a lunatic I mean
that's literally what we need to show
the country right that this guy is not
this guy is not fit to be out in public
let alone be the goddamn president of
the United States the problem is with
CNN is they're going to capitulate to
him a little bit right it's all going to
be faked up it's all fake with Trump
every [__] time it's fake with Trump
there's nothing real with that
[__] so every time you know he's
gonna put himself in a position where
CNN's gonna have to capitulate to him a
little bit
um and they're not really gonna pressure
him too much it's going to be a lot of
softballing which that's the thing I
have a problem with I mean if CNN's like
yeah come on the show we're gonna [__]
we're gonna [__] hold you account
we're gonna hold your [__] feet to
the fire sure I'm for that I think that
makes it I think that makes it better
but I'm not against him being out in
public if CNN wants to do that and
really I'm not against if you don't want
to [__] watch it don't watch it
uh someone said what's my favorite bar
in Casey I I'm guessing you mean Kansas
City
um I'm about two and a half three hours
away depending on which part of Kansas
City
um that you're talking about I I mean
I've been to several bars in Kansas City
but I don't remember the the names of
them to be frank
um so I don't know what my favorite bar
in Kansas city is I don't know that's a
good question though maybe I should
figure that out
oh
um
let's see what other questions have we
got curious why you dislike um tyt so
much Lara Lara what a great why do I
dislike tyt too so much
because it's garbage it's garbage
they they're they're they're they're
they're they're making content for money
and they want money that's that's how
that's why they're making content
because they they want money in their
content and they want people to go watch
their content so they can make money now
I'm not saying it's a bad thing to make
money that's not what I'm saying I'm not
saying the creators shouldn't make a
living because they certainly should
make a living we work hard a lot of us
work [__] hard at our content what I
what pisses me off about tyt is the
right wing spin on a left-wing narrative
because they do it all the time Jank is
not is not a [__] Democrat he's not
an independent he's a [__] Republican
folks if you're going over to tyt and
you're and you're eating that [__] up
like you love and again there's some
creators on tyt that I I'm aligned with
there's some of them that are on the
left they make [__] senses some of
the [__] they say sounds like the [__] I
say the problem is is it's not it's
always it's always seems to be packaged
in a way that both sides are the same
which is [__] that is a hundred
percent a thousand percent of [__]
lie both sides are not the same that if
someone's telling you that [__] they are
[__] lying to you that both sides are
the same
and if you buy those arguments both
sides are the same [__] then then you're
buying propaganda you're buying
propaganda for the right because the
idea is that look listen the right may
be bad they may be fascist they may be
taking away rights but so are the
Democrats so why not vote for the
Republicans because they're going to
lower your taxes okay that's the
slippery slope that you get in both
sides are not the [__] same they're
not and that's the message they sell
over there the other [__] message
they sell over there on tyt
and it's not just tyt David packman does
this [__] [__] too he does this [__]
too and I'll speak out against any
[__] that does this [__] I don't
give a damn who they are I don't care I
don't even care who I'm affiliated with
if I spot it I'll [__] call it out
but listen when you're having a
self-defeatist message where you're like
oh Democrats can't win anyways so just
don't go vote and they're not gonna give
us what we want oh Joe Biden Joe Biden
didn't fulfill every single promise that
he made what president does have you had
one [__] president one that
fulfilled every single [__] promise
no get the [__] out of here with that
[__] but if you go through Joe Biden's
promises he's one of the most effective
presidents that we've had in in modern
history now I'm not saying I'm gonna sip
for him I don't own a Biden hat or a
Biden bumper sticker [__] I don't even
talk about the [__] here on the
show and to be quite honest I'm not
gonna officially endorse any Democrat I
never will listen to me listen to me I
will never officially endorse any
Democrat never never will I be like oh
yeah I fully throat endorsing you should
go vote for this I mean I'm gonna say go
vote for [__] this person because
that one's a fascist
I mean your alternative to the [__]
Democrat in this race is a goddamn Nazi
so yeah it's an easy choice I mean if
that's an endorsement I don't I don't
think that is but the point is is that
you can't have self-defeatist attitudes
and both sidesism is a right-wing
talking point and when you go to a
left-wing show and they're Whispering
right-wing talking points into your
[__] ear it's not left-wing liberal
media it's not it's not tyt is not
left-wing liberal media it may sound
like it but it's not it's [__] not
so that's why I'm against it if that
makes sense
and I you know a lot of people get
pissed off that I'm against them but I I
again you think the [__] guy gives a
[__]
and don't give a [__] if you if you if
you're mad that I'm against you right
frankly that's what I want I want a
visceral reaction out of you because I
want you to have to [__] defend them
and I what I mean by that is defend them
in your own way and find a way to defend
what I'm saying because maybe just maybe
by you defending them maybe you'll
understand why my position is the way it
is it doesn't mean that it has to be
your position
see I think that's what's confusing
about America we've gotten confused is
we all have to think and be the same we
don't our experiences are unique that's
the beauty of it the beauty of democracy
the beauty of Liberty and really the
beauty of liberalism lowercase l or the
left whatever you want to call it
duty of liberalism is we all get to have
our own [__] ideas our own [__]
experience and we can all bring
something to the table
all of us and if we listen to each other
if we truly listen to each other's
experience
and what it means about those
experiences we can create policies in
this country with serious politicians we
can create a serious government
that will provide rights and freedoms
for people that will be the vehicle to
our Liberty and that is how we achieve
the most equity and the most equality
that we possibly can because it's never
going to be perfect
because it may be perfect for this
person but it's not for this person it
may be perfect for me but it's not
perfect for you that's where White
Privilege comes in Jesus Christ it's
been perfect for white dudes for a long
time a long [__] time even the
most disadvantaged white guys they start
at the very top [__]
that's how it's worked
but because we haven't listened to other
people's experiences and make sure those
experiences are part of our [__]
National Fabric and our system
our our system needs to be reworked to
where everyone experience is included
and how it works
and it's not taking away your privilege
because someone else is granted that
privilege it's not you're not losing
anything you're just a cuck you're just
a cuck
and I believe that everyone has their
own experience and I want to hear what
their experiences is or that what they
are
I I don't know what it means to be a
trans person I have no clue I wouldn't
even know where to start
to know what experience a trans person
has I wouldn't know where to start
to know what the experience of an lgbtq
member is I wouldn't know where to start
about a woman's experience with health
care in this country I would have no
idea can't you tell
that's why I shouldn't be telling you
what to do with your experience
but we should listen we should listen
and we should pay attention to
everyone's experience because if we all
do that even even the even the [__]
magas because folks I I I I know this
sounds crazy but most most of Maga don't
want to go broke because of a medical
bill
they truly they're [__] factories
left their towns long ago
this country abandoned those poor white
folks to give the privilege to the rich
white folks they truly did and if we
talk to them if we listen to them and
you and they listen back they have to
listen back that's one of the problems
and that that's really the actual
problem is they don't [__] listen you
can't break through it's a [__]
nightmare to try to get through to these
[__] but we can't give up just
like we shouldn't give up on any of our
countrymen we shouldn't give up on
anyone no one I don't care what you're
well I don't care what gender you want
to be or what gender you were or are I
don't give a [__] I don't I don't care
how you want to dress how you want to
make your hair what makeup you want to
wear if you want to wear this or you
want to do that you want to love this
person you want to love that person you
want to be this way you want to be that
I don't give a [__]
everyone's experience matters we're all
[__] humans
and we should stop the government
dehumanizing people people are always
going to dehumanize people [__] we got
social media right I mean come on you
think we're ever going to get rid of
humans dehumanizing other humans [__]
it's so easy nowadays that's that's one
reason why there's so many slippery
slopes
but we shouldn't be allowing people that
are setting policy in our government to
dehumanize other countrymen and other
other humans that are here
these These are us these are our people
and folks in an authoritarian fascist
regime that slippery slope when you
start allowing when you start allowing
someone else to take away rights from
other people because you're like well
I'm not trans so
my kids aren't trans so big deal who
cares oh man I'm not part of the lgbtq
community so what do I give a [__] I'm
not a woman I don't need that kind of
Health Care so what do I care who gives
them [__] no
you should care you should care every
single point and the reason why is
because if they take it from them they
can take it from you and just sit back
and wait and it'll happen because
they're never going to be satisfied with
how much they take away from people to
prop up their privilege they just won't
I won't
um uh someone says who the hell is this
gay I guess that's a legitimate question
maybe someone we can bring someone in
the answer who the hell this guy is Gabe
Sanchez who the hell is this guy on the
screen who is this guy on the screen is
it who who you me me you I don't know me
like who yeah who is this guy he's
speaking facts man holy [__] this
country bumpkin saying left-wing [__]
it's confusing I think that's probably
the problem
uh his name is is Tony Michaels yeah uh
Tony and I do a Daily Show yeah every
two hours yep
um I mean I don't know what else to say
yeah I mean he's gotta subscribe you
just gotta you just gotta comment you
gotta just you sort of you just gotta
you know you just gotta sit down grab
your popcorn because it's gonna be a
show right he's not gonna [__] around is
he oh my God so we were doing the uh um
shoot the [__] when we were waiting on
you oh yeah yeah how's it going today by
the way busy man how is it hang in there
well I'm going out of town tomorrow so
how are you you know yeah yeah oh so
you're trying to oh that's right we got
a heart out tomorrow the audience is
gonna be disappointed we're gonna have
to do bonehead and we're gonna have to
get out of here
so the so the poll needs to be this
afternoon not this evening
so that way you can get a good idea yeah
because you're gonna make the graphics
tonight yeah as long as you know and
it's like if we have anyone new that
we're gonna throw in there like I feel
like most of the people ain't always
that hard no it's not I mean because you
got to find a picture of some dumb [__]
sometimes it's hard to like it was hard
to find of that Jack Trader like there
were only two photos on the internet of
him one I mean you mean the guy and the
trader that gave away all of our
classified information on a Discord
server yeah he's a patriot hey speaking
of Traders did you see the news of
Clarence Thomas oh my God I'm so
surprised that Harlan Hitler gave him
more money I'm sorry did I did I not
call it from the very beginning I was
like dude I was like there's a first one
and I said there's no way that uh
propublica would not just be like okay
here's one and that's it right they have
other ones we found this thing yeah like
what I said was I was like
I was like I expect the third one
because the first one was he did these
luxury big occasions and he let them
stay there and five hundred thousand
dollars all this stuff in terms of what
it was and then I said and then the
second one came out
and it was revealed that he bought the
house right for his mom of Clarence
Thomas's mom and then I said the third
one uh I mean other than the fact that
we knew that Ginny Thomas got money from
Harlan Crowe in terms of like a donation
or investment whatever you want to call
it uh buying uh people uh but I said the
third one would most likely be did you
just say buying people yeah wait wait
what okay it's back up before we get to
the last one
Harlan Hitler you just said let me tell
you I know what I said and I meant what
I said hey can you give me the the uh
the transcript let me read it back to
you you said Harlan Hitler gave Jeannie
Thomas Clarence Thomas's wife money to
buy people that's what you said uh well
I guess what I meant was okay well
actually I don't know I don't know I
mean she could have bought people but
what I what I meant to say what I guess
what I was trying to say in this this
thought was right
he gave money to Jenny Thomas right for
her [__] right-wing Foundation
is it called Q Anon Foundation is that
one yeah yeah yeah you know what's funny
is I was not Elite you know what's funny
about this I was
uh I was I was editing a what was that
yeah that's coming out later today you
don't say I don't say actually I have a
new one if you don't want to play it
later oh yeah sure we if we got time
we'll play yeah yeah uh so basically
there was a joke that was in the 2011
correspondence dinner and it was
said because you were going you were
going through the course dude I pulled I
pulled out all the [__] receipt yeah
did you watch the whole thing like the
whole the whole roast part of it yeah
yeah like I went back on 2011 and 2012
were the two though I thought you were
like watching like 2010 2011 2012 13 14
15. no I went because his thing I went
2011 2012 and then I jumped to 2018. oh
I see because those are the ones that
were specifically targeting Trump right
where he's sitting in the room and he's
like grimacing exactly like he showed up
to 2011 and then never came back again
after he got [__] humiliated that's
some of the best footage by the way oh
it's so great oh yeah but in 2011 Seth
Meyers makes a joke about Ginny Thomas
because he made a tea party joke right
and he's like oh I know that in like you
know 19 years or whatever he said he was
like uh I'll be getting a call from
Jenny Thomas and I was like oh what I
was like there's a yeah so you you never
knew that little nugget until you
re-watch these and you're like oh yeah I
didn't I didn't know that he made this
like little
yeah no one would have known
that's what it's like weird it's a joke
that like if obviously people in the
room know Jenny Thomas and this was Seth
Meyers and Seth Meyers in 2011. oh 11.
yeah that's right okay he did 2011. and
so that was the one anyway he made a
joke and he was I think he was talking
about like uh Obama if you like you've
obviously aged like if you get any more
white hair in your hair like in your
head
um you'll be getting like an endorsement
from the tea party or something like
that right because he's old is that old
and white you know oh so and then and
then and then I think he said something
like uh he's like that that joke pulled
well with a Heritage Foundation and then
he made a joke about how Jenny Thomas
would be calling him
in whatever my name is crazy that he
pulled her out of that head right it's
such a like well because because
the weird thing about the correspondence
dinner and you probably uh know this
from re-watching this is they're they're
really doing it for the room not for the
nation right yeah this this performance
is for the room the other thing that's
weird about it is the room is not miked
worth of [__] normally it's not miked
it's not miked and there's not cameras
for like Teeth yeah it's not like an
award show we're like oh I know exactly
where and I got well lit and stuff well
even even a roast like a real like a
real celebrity roast they they camera
the room and they mic the room different
yeah this is this is not that way this
is really a a [__] dinner for the for
the people in Washington DC and in
particular the media
um written and TV and and a bunch of
celebrities so they can get attention
and they get people there but the main
point is is that they're doing it for
the room so everyone in the room would
have gotten the genie Thomas reference
so they wrote that joke for the room not
not for us you know not for the names of
known who the [__] that was right and I
don't and the other thing too is like
there's a moment where
I was like I don't know if he wrote that
joke or if he just improvised that joke
based on how the room responded in the
moment I I mean I'm not saying Seth
Meyers
um is is
dumb or ignorant of who Jeannie Thomas
no no no I'm saying like in terms of
making the joke like he made the Tea
Party joke so he could have had it ready
to go based on like how people responded
right because they know like because
they'll do that a lot of times because
say he hasn't worked this material right
right right like like a correspondence
dinner he he didn't go work the material
in a club for you know seven months yeah
some some jokes they they will go work
out like I was listening to Roy Wood Jr
do like a like a post-mortem kind of
like these are the jokes I did say and
these are the jokes I could not see did
he say how much of that he wrote he
wrote the whole thing oh did he no he
wrote so he wrote his jokes yeah he
wrote the jokes and nobody told him what
he could and couldn't say well because
uh Free Speech Tony right well I the
president and other speakers a lot of
time you know they're gonna have writers
yeah which maybe we should talk about
that a little more more today if we got
time which I don't know if we will but
um but the writers would write a lot of
those jokes
um and sometimes like because the person
doing the the keynote comedy a lot of
times is helping write the other jokes
that comedians will help write jokes and
they'll kind of trade back and forth and
figure out where those jokes belong
because a lot of times you're just like
writing jokes you know they're just
[__] writing jokes and then they're
trying to make sense of it right because
oh that's funny that's funny because
there's a whole there's like a whole
psychology that comes to the joke right
or rather the joke like the set that you
have right like you kind of like
especially especially if you're someone
that nobody knows right like you have to
go in and you have to establish trust
with the the audience right you have to
you have to make a joke and the first
joke out of the gate was a classified
documents joke right right it was all
right Joe Biden it was Joe Biden and he
did yeah he's like hey hey you left your
documents and he wouldn't know where to
put them anyways which is totally which
is you know it was a great deal it's a
great joke but also one where it's like
oh if he doesn't know it's coming and he
doesn't react the way that I want to
react then this [__] goes south real
quick right right and you might you
might have a few jokes lined up behind
that and if it goes south you may not
lay into them or you may go dumb like
the the Michelle wolf one I think she
told every [__] joke she had in the
chamber oh yeah she was
she she was like I'm telling every
single one of these [__] I
don't care how the rumor is right yeah
it's it's uh
because I went back to the 2018 stuff as
well and what I was is that the Michelle
wolf that's Michelle Wilkins and that's
the one and I really just focus because
I talk about how like
you know uh I think what is the thing I
say I um
whatever happened to Republicans taking
uh I I the joke I say in my what was
that to say whatever whatever happened
to Republicans taking jokes like a man
right or whatever happened to a
republican taking a joke like a man
right because they're always like oh man
our men used to go and fight in wars and
now they you know they're all these like
[__] [__] [__] you know and it's
like take a [__] joke man learn how
to laugh at yourself
dude if you're expecting Maga or any
Trump trump hump an idiot out there and
have self-deprecating humor you are you
are you're gonna wait a long time I want
to pull something up yeah yeah on this
um
um oh wait so this is this is the last
thing I was saying like there I would I
expected the one of the next drops to be
if not the third drop to be something
that was specifically about giving money
for something right right and this is
kind of along the lines of that of just
being like hey I'm gonna bankroll your
nephew well you know I misread this this
I RIS read this this morning I did not
realize it was his nephew I just
realized I thought it was just his kid
so that's what I'm asking that's what I
was gonna ask you to have a good kid so
this is a nephew
um who is like a son oh my God now I
didn't see this number
um because honestly I was more focused
on trying to figure out what the proud
boy situation was because I put that on
the thumbnail because someone didn't get
up this no I'm just kidding you had
stuff you were doing that stuff you
asked me early if I would do the
thumbnail so the thumbnail was me today
[__] so put it in the comments
who's better at thumbnails and it better
be me better now I'm just kidding
obviously Dave is better you usually
like sometimes he'll be late and I'll
make one and he'll make one and it's
like once maybe twice we've went with
mine yeah but almost every time Gabe
gets a better picture somehow he gets
better [__] pictures I do anyways
besides the point I did not know the
payments were a hundred and fifty Grand
holy [__] he gave this dude a 150 Grand
I told you I was like dude this is good
I was like he's gonna [__] he did the
luxury vacations he bought the house
he's gonna give him money for something
uh so propublica is reporting that it's
it's it's reaching up to 150 000 listen
folks I I want to give you an idea so
there's there's there's a thing where
you give people money like bags of cash
or a check right like that's overt but
then there's you overtly paying 150 000
of tuition you're gonna pay anyways that
is you someone get giving you money I
don't give a [__] what you say that is
someone giving you money the tuition at
the school the boarding school was more
than six thousand dollars a month uh
um God damn six thousand bucks hidden
hidden Lake uh Hidden Lake Academy a
private boarding school in the foothills
of Northern Georgia
so
they got dude
everything man wait a second uh is
Jeannie Thomas or Clarence Thomas from
Georgia
that's his mother's house is there okay
so so I don't know there's a lot of
money there's a lot of Ireland isn't
Jenny from Texas that's what I thought
she was born in Nebraska well that makes
sense but she spent some time in Texas
let me sure
that makes sense if you've ever met
someone from Nebraska and I'm not
disparaging people from Nebraska people
from Missouri are almost the same as
just a little bit of a difference like
we have in Missouri as opposed to
Nebraska we have like two different
colored fenders on our [__] cars like
that's the difference between Nebraska
and what it's I'm oh yeah I'm telling
the truth and maybe just maybe maybe
just maybe your trunk lid will have a
different color than the rest of your
car like that's Missouri right like
that's that's what it is that's the
difference but Nebraska it would make
sense that she would be like a religious
cult member because she was she was a
religious cult member like in the 70s
like famously and now she's another
religious cult member yeah she's a crazy
like when I look at her Wikipedia
they're like political and then it says
activists I'm like
[Music]
um
sugar-coated uh label traditionist
speaking of sedition
move on ah [__] clearance yeah I mean I
mean basically all you got to know is
again this probably won't be the last
thing that drops the next one I'm sure
like I'm I'm waiting
I'm waiting for it to become a direct
payment right well because this is this
is as close as you can get that we've
had so far right because all of it's
been oh he's my friend and he goes on
vacation with me and I'm already paying
for the yacht right I'm already paying
for the private mansion that we're
staying in I'm already paying for all
the buffet of food that these private
chefs are making he just happened to be
there and then there's that well you
know what his mother's house from him so
you the reason it's uh and I think this
is why you maybe thought it was the sun
earlier is because
laughs
uh Mark Martin the kid yeah uh was far
from home so for the previous decade he
had lived with the justice and his wife
in the suburbs of Washington DC and he
had taken legal custody of Martin when
he was six years old so that's what I
mean
like that's what the propublica
reporting kind of was which is again
which is which is which is uh because he
was the guardian of this right he was
the legal guardian of this of his nephew
and so in all purpose he was a son right
I mean he's his nephew since he was six
years old which is pretty early it's not
like oh yeah man yeah I mean they raised
him right they raised him I mean let's
just say which I'm sure he's probably
[__] crazy right um well you know
Marjorie Taylor green would say well
you're not a whoa you're not a
biological father or a biological mother
you [__] you adopted them that's what
she would say and and you had Heartland
Hitler pay 150 000 of tuition which is a
direct payment by the way come on man
yeah I mean other than like a bag of
cash you just gotta be like oh who
footed the bill it wasn't Thomas it
wasn't Clarence Thomas
it's a little different than buying a
meal for someone it's a little different
than than 200 a month right that they
were gonna be on the hook for that he
paid for them he's like no I got it
you'll get me on the back end which I
think last week which last week because
we talked about the show well you what I
I love how you're like yeah just do me a
couple give me a couple a good ones you
know what I'm talking about awesome just
run one on the back end
what the [__] oh my God man I don't know
what kind of weird cult-like [__]
they're into well [__] you know hey you
know but
cocaine field sex or you know I'm sure
I'm sure Clarence
Hitler like methamphetamine so I yeah
or I would say that Harlan Hitler
probably meth then I mean you know I'm
just saying he likes all things Hitler
so I mean you know it's pro-hitler right
yeah that makes sense but uh the other
thing was last week we learned
because we also sat on a show and we
were like there's no way that everyone's
like oh no it's totally fine it's just a
friend there he has no business in front
of the court and then what do we find oh
there's actually a company that Harlan
Hitler is connected with that did have a
business before the court and it's like
oh no [__] you didn't think about this
guy [__] like Hook Line and Sinker
knew exactly what's going on they're
just it's a friendship hey yeah yeah I
know we're playing platonic bro when are
you gonna when are you gonna pay for me
to go on a yacht [__]
anyone wants to everybody
want to give me money to give tony money
yeah that would be great that would be
great and then propublica can report on
it yeah you know what else is in a
report you know what else is breaking
news Ted's Ted Cruz's best friend he has
been found guilty found guilty of
seditious conspiracy I think this isn't
this a great picture of these two I mean
that's not the only one too there's
another one with uh with oh yeah he's
friends with all these people
there's that one let's see if I can find
these
um can you pull the oh here you go
here's your buddy the Crypt Keeper Rick
Scott
who by the way was also at the 2011
correspondent Center at the Trump table
when he was getting [__]
oh here here you go here's a and someone
put a collage together oh there we go
there you go Rick Scott Donald Trump
Donald Trump Jr looking like a little he
looks he looks like him Crenshaw he's
probably like where do I look at the
camera look at this strapless eye patch
on Dan Crenshaw doesn't that I know it's
I mean he's like I'll wear the I bet so
I look like a badass and he's like I'll
wear the strapless yeah also every one
of these photos
is an event that's happening
um inside of a few of these maybe more
than uh maybe four not three are
happening at night so he's inside at
night we're wearing sunglasses what if
you think he's Jack Nicholson he's like
no one can
no one knows I'm a danger
is this like big daddy where he puts on
the sunglasses and he's invisible is
that what you're saying yeah maybe he
thinks he's invisible or he's like no
one will know I'm the same bold guy with
the goatee beard thing going on I mean
sometimes goatee sometimes it's beer but
it's always sunglasses it's always yeah
uh yeah I don't I don't even know if it
exists I'm I'm not real sure man you
find a picture of Enrique Dario without
let me find that video that I posted of
him here's another great one here's
another great picture of him and his
buddy and I'm I'm I'm I'm just gonna say
it it feels like to me that this here
this sign here
um is the uh is is it's the white power
sign yeah he's definitely not being like
I just shot a three-pointer you know
it's like doesn't it look like and I'm
you know again
Roger Stone is a weirdo right he's a
Centric I get it and I'm I'm saying you
know and I'm one to say that sexuality
is fluid here right
um but doesn't look like Roger Stone's
holding something in his mouth I'm just
saying yeah
no I mean a shot in them I mean yeah
let's move on I don't want to get in
trouble here I don't want to get
canceled you know uh yeah you know
not today's edition did you find one oh
here's here's another here's another
great one no I found the video it's
another Heyman roads that I posted you
know yeah that's the that's the one I
want I want the one in the um in the
parking garage yep yeah yeah okay um
because both of those [__] have
now been found guilty of seditious
conspiracy
um but here's here's here here is a
terrorist and whatever that is
um next to the uh the trader that is
yeah I would call them bull terrorists
right like that right she audibly
terrorizes me right
[Music]
in Roger Stone's mouth uh see I'm I'm
gonna be bad it's it's they're gonna
catch me today probably I'm telling you
I don't see a [__] picture without
him with sunglasses on me no I mean did
you find one yeah nope nope he doesn't
have sunglasses nope he doesn't he he
always has him he always always wears
them every single room
[Music]
every oh you know what actually I did
find one oh yeah
they must have fell off or something wow
it's on his Wikipedia page oh really
wait that's the only place that he's not
wearing sunglasses honestly I'm even in
the interview he did uh yeah I think in
his deposition sunglasses sunglasses
sunglasses is he wearing them in federal
court
I
found one
is it because
um he has demon dies or something is
that why he always wears them or is he
just scared of the sun I don't know
maybe he's maybe he's like I no one
should look at my eyes right inside well
he he's not gonna be able to walk around
it's like shapes on in federal prison I
can tell you that yeah no he's not gonna
be able to do that I mean he'll be able
he'll have a hat but he won't this is I
sent you the image okay this is the um
this is the one without yeah this is not
this is not the Wikipedia one this is a
different one this one him out and about
ah now I see what it is it's the Brows
that's what it is the Brows yeah yeah he
looks goofy without the glasses it looks
a little weird you know it's like when
somebody wears a hat all the time and
then they can't right you're like oh
wait is it your short hair or no hair
and then take it off and you're like oh
that's not at all what I expected you
know right right but this is yeah this
is weird this is weird this doesn't look
like him at all does it without the
glasses I'm not used to seeing this
[__] without glass I mean I've seen
there's another photo of him with just
like glasses on not you know what he'll
be able to do I mean really honestly
when he gets out of prison he just all
you have to do is shave his face not
wear all the [__] Terrace gear no one
would know no one will know who he is he
just doesn't he can't put on a pair of
Shades Amber and again yeah
and he can't wear the color black or
yellow right well and then when and then
you know and then and then when he goes
places you know he'd have to I don't
know he I mean
you would probably have to change try to
change his name right but who knows well
I yeah you know he he'll probably try to
capitalize on it to be quite honest all
these [__] [__] boxes do yeah all
every single one of these January wasn't
he selling merch on January 6th like
because he wasn't at January 6th well
that's capital that's what I want to
talk about because that's the most
significant thing and that's why I want
you to pull that clip from the parking
garage yeah yeah with um Stuart Rhodes
uh The Oath Keepers
um of course Enrique atario of proud
boys and then what's her name with the
um Beyond Latinos for Trump yeah and
that what it's called Latinos for Trump
yeah yeah yeah and and then there was
one other member of a group there they
were having a four yeah four way with
each other yeah
yeah yeah I don't know they really
[__] up I tweeted it I tweeted this
video last March that's crazy that's
it's been a long time man yeah because
it was right before
because it was right before the the gym
because it was hard to find that and
then you had to go out and find it and
yeah and post it
do a lot of do a lot of stuff man I'm
not proud of you know right and the
other thing I want people to know that
Enrique tario isn't the founder of The
Proud boys he's just a leader at the
time of the Insurrection
um the actual founder of The Proud boys
is Gavin McGinnis we talked about him on
the show but dildo yeah so Gavin
McGinnis um he's a weirdo but he he to
prove that he was or wasn't a homosexual
I'm not really sure what his aim was
it's like that scene in DodgeBall where
he's like bold move cotton Oh I thought
it was like if you could Dodge a wrench
you can dodge a ball if you can dodge a
dildo you can dodge a ball you can dodge
I don't I don't know but Gavin McGinnis
on air on his show this is what uh kind
of was his downfall if you want to say
with his audience is he
inserted um a silicone shaft into his um
you know
backside to prove that he wasn't or is
I'm not sure what the proof what they
was trying to prove but it it's it's one
of those things
I'm gonna yeah because it's like I'm
gonna prove I'm not gay by doing
something that that they typically like
that people you might think would do
like I don't think it's a weird strategy
I mean I'm I'm not I'm not gonna say I
don't I don't think sticking a sex toy
where we're talking about is inherently
gay right no no I'm saying I'm not
saying it's gay because I mean there's
obviously like I mean it can't be
anything it could be I guess I I don't
know it's it's it you know it's it's
it could be painful it could be
pleasureful I don't know I mean you know
there's the whole it's a spectrum sex
and pleasure is a spectrum okay
and orientation is a spectrum especially
when you're talking about sex toys like
lube and stuff but here's when you got a
shadow dick but here's where what I am
saying is that I don't know on this show
if I'll ever jump the shark by live
streaming sticking something in my ass
I'm just saying hey how about this if
you do let me know well and will you
please will you please stop me that's
all I ask you're like oh yeah you know
remember that one show where you were
talking about Gavin McGinnis and that
you should never jump the shark by
sticking in your maybe we should review
that footage I'm just saying here's the
video of a bunch of dildos speaking of
dildos standing around in a parking
garage trying to overturn our government
again you see here in that in the Hat
holy [__] he doesn't have does he no he
does he does he does it oh he does okay
it's just hard to watch you'll see it
from another angle okay so this is hard
to see in this angle um and then Stuart
Rhodes is standing here behind him this
lady which one is the Latinos for Trump
is that's all right there in the orange
jacket yeah okay so who is this person
uh in the black chick isn't that Kelly
Sorrell or is the other way is that
Kelly surreal okay once say play it then
we'll know okay let's uh let's let's
play it and you guys can listen to the
seditious conspiracy that was happening
in a parking garage and they were
documenting it it's kind of crazy
several of his members have also been
arrested and prosecutors allege some
Oath Keepers may have been planning the
attack as early as November Rhodes
himself has not been arrested
[Music]
he's joined by Stuart Rhodes founder of
The Oath Keepers militia
routes
I love the [__] accent don't you yeah
well what's funny so here's the thing so
that video was on YouTube and there's a
there's a longer version that was on
YouTube
and they did a documentary Channel 4 of
the British uh news well the proud boys
in the oathkeepers were like hey come
right all right so they had ever like
they had they had footage of him going
to the courthouse the that day right and
they were like look you got her the day
before and they're like look you got to
get the [__] out of DC because he did it
was after he had got in trouble you're
talking about Enrique tario yeah because
he wasn't supposed he was barred from DC
the judge said you cannot enter the city
limits yeah and that was after he had
been found guilty of burning the black
lives matter flag that was outside the
church got in trouble they said you
gotta go he said okay I'll go I'll go
and then what we find out is that the
the night of the fifth January 5th they
met in a parking garage to have this
Shady seditionist meeting and uh it was
all part of this documentary right and
this document this like little
documentary gets
put online and because they're like we
get we have this segment and this is a
documentary it got [__] pulled down
because the documentary
uh the documentarian
was then brought in yeah they were
subpoenaed right and it was subpoenaed
and he and they pulled that footage down
and that's how and that's why it was
tough for us to find right you found it
and that's why we reposted it because
[__] them you know what I mean yeah
right I mean it took it yeah it took a
lot of digging and uh [__] sleuthing
but I found it but yeah the reason they
took it down was because they were using
it as evidence to show
in the actual Jan six hearings and
that's when they brought him in guess
what [__] the internet's forever
um speaking of the internet forever so I
don't normally show polls right and I'm
gonna get what kind of polls
oh my god get your [__] mind out of
it oh I don't know I'm like we we have
polls on the show all the time because
we do polls for uh right uh for bonehead
well that's our pull that's that's kind
of that's we're making jokes I'm talking
about actual pulls but that's what I'm
asking like what kind of polls well this
poll here is is a uh is a Twitter poll
oh that's not a real poll right I I know
it's are any pull will you bear with me
I'm trying to get through the bit here
God damn it
I'm trying to get through the transition
so we don't normally show polls because
polls are [__] rather they're Twitter
polls or they're done by some [__]
polling agency they're [__] they're
normally just absolute trash and this
one is trash but it's hilarious uh I
sent it to you last night it's from a
representative named Jason Zachary in
Tennessee he thought he thought he would
take to Twitter and he'd be like hey hey
everybody out there on Twitter now that
it's a bunch of rat Wingers let's see if
they think it's the guns right and you
know what I'm talking about so the guy's
like he loads the question even this is
[__] hilarious he loads the question
what do you feel is the core issue
driving the evil acts of violence we are
seeing in our country like he loads it
right
he says sin dummy mental health what do
you care even though you're a legislator
you're not gonna fix that problem and
then break down a family what the [__]
does that mean and then guns and I don't
know if you can break down because the
breakdown of family they're gonna what
they're trying to do is they're sounding
like oh the nuclear family right if you
don't have uh both parents in the
household yeah but I I think it's a more
of a dog whistle than that I think the
dogs
you can't have two mommies and two
daddies
also I think it's also a dog whistle
against them being like Oh look The the
breakdown of the family happens within
the black community right and it's
always absolutely yeah that's why
they're all having to play well yeah and
that's but breakdown of family what does
that mean break
I'm racist right well I mean so is sin
man he's like I'm a white Christian
nationalist sin really listen if you
think if you think people committing sin
is the problem of committing sin you're
a dumbass you are a stupid [__] like I I
will commit all of the I you know what I
will go against the Ten Commandments
everything that God said not to do I
will do those things and then say but
I'm still a Christian right the sins
that you guys right right right oh my
God but poor poor poor Jason right and
it and he's appropriately named here
Jason Zachary he's got two first names I
don't know that you know listen these
people with these two first names yeah
these people these two first names you
can't trust them these people with these
two first names you know what I'm
talking about you can't trust these
[__] but Jason Zachary here
this did not go the way he wants so his
final result man he racked up some votes
a hundred and thirteen thousand almost
yeah that's a lot of votes for a Twitter
poll man I'm surprised that he even
threw guns in there
he was expecting the opposite result
right because he loaded it because we
try this all the time too where we try
to load the choice that we want in the
first spot and we know the ones we're
gonna get is in the last spot but we try
to load and see if it makes a difference
sometimes it does maybe it doesn't maybe
it's just because like we try that with
bonehead all the time like we're trying
to reload them or something yeah like
yeah well okay audience we'll be honest
we're trying to [__] [__] yeah yeah
but also like if someone was on the pole
the previous week then I will change the
order right so that they're not in the
same spot you know right so it doesn't
look like we just copy and paste which
we totally did not do
no no but but we don't load the bonehead
question right we're just like who's the
owner of the week we don't even use it
we don't even explain why like we're not
like here's this season we say comment
your reason right and some people last
year people don't but it's just like who
is the bonehead of the week
here are the contestants and then tell
us why if you want to it's the it's a
very neutral question
and then usually down in the comments so
like why can't I select all of them yeah
why is there all of the above for like
because we can't make all of the above
because if we did all the books like the
[__] guns right it would look like
this every [__] week and we would
have to be like well all the above one
all the above
every episode I would be making Graphics
I had everyone always on the winner
right well they would just be all of the
above yeah
this week you know right everyone kind
of people have to like they have to be
clear winners you know and sometimes we
have to take people off the bonehead
pole because they lived there for like
four weeks like George Santos who lived
in the bonehead boat for like six weeks
in a row so we're like man we can't have
him on there again we got to make him
the the dinner speaking of George Santos
uh yeah and it's actually going to be
the what was that that I have coming up
is for the White House Correspondence
Dinner yeah he made a video
preemptively before the the dinner it
was like I've been told on good
authority that I'm the number one roast
like the topic of roasting at the White
House correspondence any jokes one joke
came in did the classified joke and I
forget if he did another joke and oh he
yeah he did he did a self-deprecating
joke and then he hit it with the George
Santos joke which was George Santos is a
journalist that was awarded blah blah
blah scholarship at at this dinner right
of course that's a hundred percent the
truth right and that was the only joke
that he got the only [__] jokey guy
so it was pretty funny to uh it was
pretty funny to see him be like I've
been told on good authority I'm good
like of all the newsworthy things that
happened he's like I'm gonna beat out
everything else
I'm the biggest liar so they're gonna
make the biggest jokes about me so the
more the story here is that Jason is a
[__] idiot the moral of the story is
it's the guns
and clearly people even on Twitter think
it's
the guns like I'm sure I wonder if we
made a poll that said
what do you think is the leading problem
uh
the the what it what do you what would
you say is the leading cause of gun
violence in America
guns
it's the guns
it's the [__] guns
[__] me it's the guns it's always the
gun [__] me it's always been the [__]
guns right like I would love to see that
pull put it up all right do it right now
I'm sure I'm sure it would be the the
last one I mean it doesn't cost us
anything to do polls I mean it costs
Jason here his reputation on how you
should put a Twitter poll I'm surprised
you didn't delete this man he's gotta
feel like an [__] here right yeah man
it's something oh well [__] Jason and
again that's about the only poll I'm
gonna show you here on the Tony Michaels
podcast uh let's see what what else did
I have oh [__] you know we missed
yesterday and you know what we might
have to do how long is your what was it
how long is it uh is it six minutes it's
uh it's like seven something like I mean
there's a 30 second thing at the end so
it's like eight minutes so you don't
know what we should do let's do like a
preview of it all right if we run out of
time if we run out of time yeah yeah I
want to play part of it at least but the
one thing I want to get to that we
[__] missed yesterday I I don't want
to go without talking about for too long
because it's gonna it's is the Tucker
Carlson [__] text message so now you
tweeted this with the actual text
message from January 7 2021 uh yeah note
the date is the day after the
Insurrection
um you tweeted this text message from
Tucker Carlson contributed to a chain of
events
that ultimately led to him getting fired
um
quote from the text message I found
myself this is Tucker Carlson quoting
here
he was texting this now this is to a
producer correct yeah one of the show
producers okay so this is one of the
show producers he's texting here in a
private thread he says quote I found
myself rooting for the mob against the
man hoping they'd hit him harder kill
him I really wanted them to hurt the kid
I could taste it oh my God man so what
do you mean because this text message
isn't isn't um that start a big chain of
events like text message events that got
him fired you're saying the this coming
to light
right yeah because what happened was
they explain that to us and then we'll
read a little bit so there was a there
is a New York Times article that came
out last week
um that basically said on the eve of the
Dominion case
uh starting trial this was a Monday or
yeah yeah right yeah yeah it was like
because they pushed it back and they
delayed it because they were trying to
really happen their agreement it was it
was it was going to finally take place
and then they're like great jury's been
selected we're all good to go and then
like and they settled the case it was
like minutes right yeah yeah well right
before right before the judge was gonna
appoint a special master
um because that was that was the next
that was right that was in response to
Fox News being like oh we didn't give
you everything my bad and then judge was
gonna be like yeah
Tucker Carlson wanted someone to die so
so then yeah so then what happens is
there's this article that comes out last
week from New York Times and they reveal
that uh these execs for whatever reason
finally got wind of these messages and
clips videos whatever and some of those
things have been leaking to Media
Matters some aren't as bad but I think
there's like an overall strategy
um
which I'll talk about in a second but
the message is that they they talked
about in this initial article from New
York Times They said oh well uh it
looked like there were some some text
that that caused Executives to be kind
of worried right of the things that he
was saying
and again all of this stuff will become
public it I mean it has now but all the
stuff will become public through the
trial and I think a lot of that stuff
they were trying to avoid you know
tarnishing the brand and and making
fault in many ways and and this and that
and so this is one of those messages
that they say kind of like
sounded the alarm for the fox execs to
be like ah uh you know what we should
actually reconsider this I don't know if
it's a good idea to go full force in
this trial
and I wouldn't be I mean I'm I'm very
confident that there's going to be other
text messages just like I believe so you
don't think this is the worst one
no I don't think it's worse dude let's
read this one then are you are you he
says a lot of crazy [__] on on the show
right I know this is the first one yeah
because the only he's like I wanted to
kill him and then when we get to the end
he's like oh should I be feeling he's
feeling his way yeah he kind of cucks on
himself yeah okay so listen to this
again this is from January 7th 2021 this
is the day after the Insurrection so
he's speaking about the Insurrection
specifically after witnessing it
um on the live footage
um the feed that he was getting
so here's what he says Tucker Carlson
tweet our uh text one of his producers a
couple weeks ago I was watching a video
of people fighting in the street in
Washington a group of trump guys
surrounded an antifa kid and started
pounding a living [__] out of him
it was three against one at least
jumping a guy like that is dishonorable
obviously
it's not how white men fight he can't go
without the racism I mean gotta say he's
gotta get the white supremacist white
men throw the fisticuffs up what what
does he think because your skin is white
you're more honorable when you fight
trust me when I say this listen if you
ever got in a fight with me I don't give
a [__] what color you are I don't care
if you're six foot if you're five five
I'm gonna fight dirty I'm gonna pick
something up and I'm gonna [__] beat
you with it that's how I was raised the
place that I came from you didn't fight
[__] fair man that is not how you
fought this white man [__] what is he
talking about like we carry around
boxing gloves with us like ooh you want
to do let me just roll up my sleeves and
put these gloves on what though he's
like let me just a [__] throw some
Gunpowder in my [__] muscle come on
man again where I came from you didn't
fight fair because if you fought fair
you got your ass kicked yeah like you
the Assumption the Assumption unless
you're in a a confined space or like you
have set restrictions
yeah I know I know and then Street dude
anything goes [__] there are no rules
is there a video clip of that he's
talking about here that people have
found yeah they don't yeah okay so so he
goes on to say once he gets past his
white supremacy here because he thinks
white men fight different or some [__]
they've they they fight pure oh yeah
pure blooded fight or some [__] well I
don't know he's a racist so it's not
surprising that he had to throw that in
there it's just funny that he he throws
the dog whistles in with the text from
his producer right they write this [__]
into the show but he's writing it into a
private text to his producer it's kind
of weird
um I mean it is Tucker Carlson so what
should I read it in Tucker's little boys
oh God
not suddenly I found myself rooting for
them I can't do it the mob against the
man hoping they'd hit him harder kill
him that's the part where he wants the
kid quote kid
okay he's calling him a kid uh to die I
I really wanted him them to hurt the kid
I could taste it he says oh my God
what the [__] he could taste it
I mean I've been in some fights in my
day right yeah and I I never tasted a
fight I've I've watched you know what
that's called that's called uh oh yeah
uh [__] being a Nazi
um that's called No honestly but it's
it's the
the like oh there's got to be some sort
of psychology anger right that like oh
God I got a uh all based on the idea of
like
how this person identifies how they
present themselves right just just just
based on the way in which they they look
and they well you send me the clip is he
antifa quote unquote in the clip or have
you watched oh it's just a [__]
protester looks like oh okay okay well
let's let's continue I think Ben
Tucker's and then we'll watch the clip
the Tucker watch and see if we can if we
get the same visceral feeling that we
want them to kill the kid I I don't know
maybe we'll get there but I doubt it
um he goes on to say then somewhere deep
in my brain oh my god
listen man when you're typing out Alex
Jones type lizard brain [__] stuff yeah
come on man so he says Tucker Carlson he
really texts this [__] then somewhere
deep in my brain an alarm went off this
isn't good for me he says I'm becoming
something that I don't want to be oh
just now you're realizing that the the
funny thing is that he is literally like
it's not like he's like saying this on a
call or saying in video right when
you're sending a text you could be like
okay no I shouldn't say that thank you
yeah oh man he literally just goes like
it's almost like he did speech to text
and he was like so there I was watching
this video and I really wanted to
[__] jump in on the fight myself and
I wanted but I would give my ass key to
the kids but then I realized I had a bow
tie on
oh my God oh my God so is there a way
for you to write a parody of this or
even maybe get AI to write a parody of
this since there's a writer strike I
don't know I'm just saying okay let's
let me I'll take it I'll take it and
I'll spit it I'll I'll tell you what
chat EBT comes up okay so um let's
continue to um it says uh um I'm
becoming something that I don't want to
be yeah
um no none of us want you to be that by
the way Tucker uh the antifa creep is a
human being oh man he finally realizes
that people are humans that's incredible
also the ability he's like oh this kid's
antifa like what the [__] okay so he
says much as I despise what he says and
does much as I'm sure I'd hate him
personally if I knew him I shouldn't
gloat over his suffering oh man his
conscience is kicking in on this text
message I should I should be bothered by
it I should remember that somewhere
somebody probably loves this kid and
would be crushed if he was killed if I
don't care about those things if I
reduce people to their politics
how am I better than he is I'm decided
I'd read it in his Cadence yeah this is
[__] crazy man okay so why you're
doing that let's watch the clip that
Duggar was talking about so I don't know
if this is the clip but I think so this
is an article that was linked underneath
of someone's like I think they're
talking about this so he may or may not
be talking about this right so this was
they said way to see well the the chugs
of tick tock commented on and said wait
is he talking about the one or the
people that were hospitalized with stab
wounds by proud Boys in December
translation device works ah son of a
[__] hey man let me yeah yeah I'm gonna
mute this thing real quick chat GPT is
writing this thing for me
oh is it uh-huh okay let me I told it I
told it to rewrite the message in the
style of satire and parody so
it's taking a minute to to work through
[__] Tucker's white supremacy uh
vitriolic murder attacks
chat need PT's like wait wait you want
me to make jokes about what yeah okay so
here's the clip that some people are
assuming uh this was released by The
Guardian
um now not in in conjunction with this
text message yes some people are
thinking that this is the clip Tucker I
don't know if this is from the I haven't
watched this video uh I've never seen it
it's only a minute long so let's watch
it
now let me unmute it here
so these are proud boys on the ground
I haven't seen three on one yet yeah I
haven't seen it yet
so this seems like this is um part of
the Million Man March is that what this
was the Maga the Maga remember when they
were gonna go look for them
yeah they like where's the campus of the
Electoral College here they are Marching
towards the college
holding their white supremacy I still
don't see scroll down the article I
think it might be a photo
yeah and I don't I I and maybe it was
one of the first little bits there yeah
maybe
um but that's um
I don't know
I mean there's a lot of fighting so it's
it's probably hard to determine what
exactly the clip he was talking about
but that may or may not be one of the
clips but I mean it it literally is just
it um the idea is is that it's that it's
um
um what he's saying here in in his text
message is that it's probably proud boys
um because they say a group he says a
group of trump guys which that's kind of
funny right that's more than likely
proud boys and now they're [__]
convicted of seditious conspiracy I mean
[__] around find out oh my God I mean
you can't get any more dude you're on
the wrong side of History Tucker and
you're spelling it out here writing your
text message to your producer but what
did you mean exactly by this is what led
to Tucker getting fired I mean what do
you think so what about well this is
like obviously not all of them but I
think that it created a perfect the
liability of it I think liability but
also like the the brand I mean like
remember that at the end of 2022 Fox
News had about four billion dollars in
cash and cash equivalents you're looking
at a 1.6 billion dollar defamation
lawsuit and a two point 0.7 billion
dollar defamation lawsuit those together
get you
4.3 billion dollars right A lot of them
is a lot of a lot of money right I mean
even even for Harlan Hitler that would
be some scratch right and I don't know
what the payment plan is for that kind
of [__] but you mean like monthly
payments yeah like if you're like oh
I'll put it on layaway and I gotta come
back and pay off later but did you say
layaway yeah I don't know oh my God
does Walmart still have layaway well I
don't know if they charge you for it but
I remember one time you'd be like oh for
five dollars I can put this and I can
come back and reserve it you know yeah
which is a crazy business model but I
used to dude I used to put a ton of [__]
on layaway I used to put a ton of [__]
on layaway I mean because you know I had
to buy like alcohol in between right
like yeah like you know
[__] you know yeah yeah no I get it I
can stretch out your money man yeah yeah
yeah so so you think you think that
there's worse text messages coming and
that's the reason why Fox News said this
is just untenable there's no way we're
gonna be able to explain this yeah I
think Fox News was hoping that these
things wouldn't be released and I think
that when you've centered your program
around this main person right you have a
streaming service that subscription
service Fox Nation that is solely
centered around Tucker Carlson they call
that the Tucker Carlson originals and
that what they call it yeah original and
so I I I mean his name is in there yeah
yeah yeah and the other thing too is
that 8 P.M spot with all the eyes on
that spot he's the most viewed person on
that Network right because of that and
they're still it's still not doing well
I mean even with the new guy after Brian
Kilmeade went on last week he [__]
[__] the bed they ended up with 1.33 or
less than that by the end of the week
why would they think that Brian kill me
could hold an audience yeah I don't know
then they got a new guy on but I
ultimately think that at the end of the
day the reason that they made the
decision to
to fire him this played a part I think
this text message and there's probably
other ones considering what he said on
the show before and what he said not
that Tucker Carlson has ever [__]
embarrassed or ashamed of that stuff
like he's said terrible things where
like in those audio recordings
that Media Matters were covered back in
2018 he said some terrible things and
then when he got busted for it he was
like oops I said some naughty words and
that was pretty much how he responded
and it was like okay we're gonna brush
it off and move on it's kind of like the
Stephen Crowder video we showed
yesterday where he was he's been
allegedly saying and he was showing his
genitalia to his staff member so he
releases a video about it not
apologizing but showing his genitalia to
his staff members like wow that's uh I
have okay quick side note uh so I gave
chat GPT yeah the uh is it good the text
message and I told it to write it in a
certain style and it said uh ladies and
gentlemen have you ever found yourself
in a situation where you're watching a
video of people fighting out I haven't
read this yet uh where you're watching
watching a video of people fighting on
the street and suddenly you're rooting
for the bad guys no just me all right
then a couple weeks ago I stumbled upon
a video of a group of trump supporters
who's surrounded antifa kid and started
beating him like they owed him money
or like he owed the money now don't get
me wrong I know that jumping a guy like
that is dishonorable it's not how white
men fight or any men for that matter but
something strange happened I found
myself hoping to hit him kill him even I
could taste it but then like a light
bulb moment I realized that this isn't
good for me I'm becoming something I
don't want to be the antifa creep is a
human being sure I despise what he says
and what he does and I'm sure I hate him
personally and I didn't know him but
I shouldn't gloat over his suffering I
should be bothered by it I should
remember that somewhere somebody loves
his kid and be crushed if he was killed
if I didn't care about those things if I
reduce myself to those politics how am I
better so it's pretty much rewriting the
same thing
so it there it is true they're the
parody of themselves yeah
whoa whoa this is parody yeah what is
this a joke like I can't rewrite this
joke
um yeah because like this is why we need
good writers in Hollywood because even
chat GPT can't always make a joke out of
something so I just I just had it
generate a new thing and now let's put
in chat gbt in it so it goes now I know
what you're thinking that's not right
chat EBT that's how I can fight and
you're right and you're damn right it's
dishonorable but the thing guys I found
myself rooting there's nothing hey
Championship what are you doing
you're becoming something you don't want
to be
chill out oh my God you confused chat
GPT yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm continuously
trained as we're talking I'm
continuously training this thing based
on how I wanted to answer and uh letting
it know the response of how if whether I
like it or I don't like the response and
each time it's going to keep refining it
but it's one of those things
where again you just can't parody parody
right like here here's okay it goes
three against one not cool man but then
I don't know what happened I guess I got
caught up in the moment of something
because suddenly I'm rooting for the mob
like yeah I get him beat him up make him
regret ever putting on that stupid mask
oh my God okay chat gbt I'll have to
give you some credit you are uh yeah
there are sometimes chatty BD can make a
funny joke that needs to be punched up
but other times you're like all right
that was just inherently funny so let's
let's talk about the writer strike for a
minute yeah yeah here we go so what what
what's the updates here uh I saw a funny
sign the other day saying um their
demands were they want to get paid and
they want Batgirl to return
um
people want to see Batgirl apparently
that girl has been put in the trash can
for DC Comics as as well she resets that
show was put in the so that show the
reason that show that sorry no not that
show that movie
was it's a it's a movie and it had
Brendan Fraser Brendan Frazier played
the villain I was really excited for it
and the reason is they've got it they've
got it it's all done right
yeah it was done it was finished right
Brandon Frazier's he's like yeah I I did
the film they're just not gonna release
yeah yeah yeah and so uh basically what
happened was James Gunn came in
and was like this movie doesn't match up
with the rest of our plans because I
will say this when it comes to Marvel
Disney the MCU they they know how to
plan out and they're like great it is
out we got this we got this even before
that right they were like we know where
this thing is headed we know exactly
where to go we know how to plan for it
right they're playing in like four
decades in advance yeah yeah but when it
comes to DC they're like we're gonna
throw these and you're like all right
great Superman Batman we gotta go
Justice League and then you're like oh
no we're gonna we're gonna bring in Joss
Whedon we're gonna [__] ham it up
instead of it being like the dark thing
that Zack Snyder wanted and then it
doesn't have a cohesive theme for these
other films that we're doing and then
we've got you know the else verse series
uh which is like there's the main
there's the main DC's and there's the DC
EU which is the universe but then like
okay that's else worlds which is like uh
uh like in the same way that you could
play it off as
um uh Multiverse like right in inside
yeah so that's how they're playing with
it but they're confusing it's confusing
doing it because now you're gonna have
you've got the Batman you've got the
Batman movie with Robert Pattinson its
own thing right Joker not even connected
its own thing not even connected
those are just good films on its own
that are just like we're gonna do our
own thing we're gonna focus on the
Batman was good I enjoyed Batman I mean
I enjoyed it after I [__] got done
taking a nap in the middle of it that
thing's like 12 hours long man no it's
not wait the reason was Robert Pattinson
yeah that thing's way too no it's not
yeah man no you know it's long the third
one in the Nolan Trilogy or the second
one in the Nolan Trilogy that one's long
what what you mean the one with the Dark
Knight that's a that's the best one I'm
not saying it's not good oh I enjoy it
but I'm saying it is long like
you better if you're gonna make a long
film you better make it interesting I'm
just saying well you know what you know
what we didn't get also which I think
should be on another demand list
Nicholas Cage was supposed to play
Superman at once yeah that was it yeah
why the [__] didn't we get the Nick Cage
Superman politics and this is the old
stuff I mean there's videos on YouTube
that people can look up where you can
actually watch him do the same thing
like yeah because he because they did a
photo shoot right and they were trying
to figure out if they could actually
make it happen and for people who don't
know this basically the idea behind that
uh Superman film which again you know
Tim Burton did the first two Batmans uh
and he was gonna do the Superman film
and the idea was gonna make it more was
gonna make it realistic and you're
talking about the Tim Burton films with
Michael Keaton yeah yes Batman who by
the way comes Michael Keaton comes back
in the [__] well if they get if we
get these [__] Riders back to work
well this is finished so it's gonna
happen anyway well right yeah yeah but
it's one of yeah so anyway
James Gunn has come into DC and he's
making changes and I think it's for the
better if anyone yeah doesn't doesn't
remember I mean obviously you have you
have the third Guardians of the Galaxy
coming out this weekend yes don't and
tomorrow yeah I think I think midnight
tonight actually yeah I'm gonna oh I
just I just realized today is May 4th so
any Star Wars fans out there May 4th the
fourth be with you
um political peace is uh Nick Cage
Superman question mark question mark go
to Google after the show
these writers need to make big demands
and the Nick Cage Superman and Batgirl
then this may be some demands that they
need to make so how long do you think
it's Gonna Last you're out there in L.A
how long do you think this is gonna last
hard to say man I mean they're out there
picking in the line right now uh and we
went down there and no no I haven't gone
again I've got friends who are who I see
Instagram stories from right down there
who are actually part of wga and are
there picketing some people even I've
got a buddy who has his own show uh the
called the Grand crew on NBC
and he is uh he's picking in right now
he's a writer and um he's on the show as
well but
the demands aren't crazy it's like hey
acknowledge me
right we just want um can you just pay
us because again people need to realize
the last time the writer strike happened
was for about a hundred days I think in
2007 2008 okay and that happened a long
time ago that happened way before the
streaming services came into existence
that's like Obama okay that's that is
Obama Bush that's Bush Obama era yeah
that transition 308 that was Obama so if
you don't know American histories I
didn't know this until I I sent you a
thing yesterday but I or yeah I think
you sent no I sent it to you uh the
reason in 2007 NBC was considering
canceling The Apprentice
right strike happened and when the
writer strike happens you'll see
there'll be like a blossoming uh or like
a bloom of of reality TV because reality
TV you don't need writers right right
yeah people because the script is just
put these people in a situation
producers behind the scenes that are
like poking the buttons and saying like
do this do that so what we might see
because people need to be like we need
people to see keep watching our station
or our streaming service or whatever
they may very well just like green light
a bunch of reality TV oh what happened
in 2007 was they were they were like
we're gonna we're gonna end The
Apprentice we're gonna stop it we're
gonna kill it it's not good
the writer strike happened and then in
2008 and they were like we're doing
Celebrity Apprentice and then they were
like let's just get a bunch of them
exactly they're like we only have to
make one change The Apprentice was [__]
there was only yeah yeah object of
America that watched that trash and then
when the celebrities came in everyone
watched it because they watched their
favorite celebrity act like an [__]
on that show right and so now we have we
had we had Trump as a president as a
result of him having the show he created
this [__] canceled that in 2007 man
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ writer strike
created Donald Trump the president so if
that happens then
I don't know what's gonna happen now we
just can't tell ask Chad GPD
um speaking of celebrities but not not
doing wild things he's actually doing a
good thing here I think Rob Lowe is
picking with the writers
um which is is good to see the
solidarity with them but here's the clip
it's it's not very long uh of Rob Lowe
um walking with the people who write his
jokes
um and write his scripts that he acts
out
um they he works because they work watch
this
solid areas so many people Mike sure who
I've loved working with my son John Owen
who I've created over Netflix with you
know we're only as good as the writing
we get so there you are we're only as
good as the writing we get and and I
wanna I just want to point out I there's
a yeah so Mike my cruiser says 100 days
as I thought and then uh melee says
you're wrong okay so let me just clarify
this
reality shows those writers are
different than other writers right so
you want to say non-union is correct but
also
the reason we have reality shows is
because it doesn't require Union writers
you've got a premise you've got greenlit
you've got producers you got people on
set you might have people who are like
oh we can write this into the general
story what you're saying is during a
strike because what happened on Union
writers in 2000 they would still be able
to work exactly exactly it's the same
reason like you're a non-union actor
versus Union actor Union actors can't do
or like non-union actors can't do Union
actors unless they're like
it's called taft-hartley there's a
different way to go about it anyway but
in this example here I just want to I
just want to point this out like yes it
is true but it's true because in 2007 or
in 2008
um the the the like I said the the blue
this Bloom of reality TV shows came to
be because it didn't require the same
writers when it didn't require the same
people to be involved that were on
strike that were part of the Union so
this is true I just want to clarify that
uh I'm not wrong I'm not wrong but I do
want to I do want to clarify that the
reality shows existed and were able to
become popular in that time frame
because they needed to fill the Gap with
content that they couldn't get from
actual Union writers that were producing
the shows that were currently
broadcasting or that were currently in
development or what have you and that's
the reason again on the on the example
for The Apprentice is it was going to
get canceled
and then they were like uh well why
don't we just like slightly modify this
a little bit and we make it the
Celebrity Apprentice and now again the
writer strike created the [__]
uh uh the [__] president that's what
happened
look at what happened man I'm saying
that [__] it's true it's true so okay I
think the tweet that I sent you was like
this is what happened so you just give
the writers whatever they [__] want
man right just give it to them just do
it okay don't be [__] around with our
timeline again don't do it I don't want
another one of these I don't want this
to happen again speaking of great
writers and great art
um a lot of people because it is May the
4th and May the 4th be with you a lot of
people are debating what is your
favorite Star Wars film
um so I want all the people here if you
like Star Wars or even if you don't I
don't give a [__] space bubbles tell me
that's my favorite Star Wars film tell
me what your face tell me in the chat
what your favorite Star Wars film is
um to date and Gabe Sanchez what is your
favorite Star Wars film uh
um
you know
what the [__] you ain't got this on the
tip of your time I would probably say
Return of the Jedi would be my number
one okay um that's it the original one
the original the yeah the original
episode one
no not episode one that's oh yeah I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry Revenge of the
Sith no no that's uh
the I will say this I do have a new
founder I think there's our generation
grew up with episode one through three
right and I don't think people
appreciated it back when it happened
and I think now as you mean Phantom
Menace and yeah yeah Clone Wars Revenge
of the Sith yeah is that what you're
saying yeah in the 90s they made those
movies no no no no not done end of it
was like 99 whatever they started it in
the 90s no I will say uh Danny cooked
his room Rogue one is pretty good that's
the best one that's the both one is a
pretty good one because it's a
standalone story it's pretty good which
if you watch Andor if you watch Andor
nope do you want me to tell you
objectively wine Rogue one is the best
Star Wars movie ever here is why
end the very [__] end of Rogue one it
is an absolute
seamless Trends and you know how I love
my transitions oh yeah it is an absolute
seamless Transit I mean this a seamless
transition from Rogue one
to the original film
do you know here's a fun fact here's the
fun fact my friend is uh she's an
animator at ilm okay
and she worked on she's worked on a ton
of Star Wars projects and non-star Wars
projects
um but they used her as a um as a model
for Princess Leia
what
so she because she has a similar kind of
bone structure you mean like in the film
in the film so obviously like you know
you don't see her face all right but
they but they used do you think he's
full of [__] I'm telling you man it's
true it's true it's true but what
happened was uh they used her because
again like that team is so big and like
she was on a team of like three or four
people that were working on just the
shadow of I forget what his name is but
he he died and they brought him back
um and then anyway it doesn't matter the
point is she and and they were looking
for someone in the studio to be like oh
we need someone to use as a model to
reference this out right because we have
existing stuff but we need a live model
to actually perform the action
and that we can we can model we can uh
we can design around
so yeah that's her May the fourth
be with you if you're a Star Wars fan or
not and a lot of people are arguing that
Revenge of the Sith on Twitter is the
most popular it is not Rogue one is the
best rogue one is pretty good objective
not my number one but it's pretty good
no but also again now again if you're
watching if you watch Andor then you get
the whole then you get the stories I'm
talking about the films though not the
series
the films that you know which one I
didn't like [__] the Han Solo one
yeah that one's trash that one was not
good that took a lot of though the only
part of that that I did like was Donald
Glover Donald Glover was great he was he
was great he put a lot of work yeah into
making sure he was authentic yeah it was
great but that film was trash yeah
anyways anyways thanks for joining us on
May the 4th May the 4th be with you make
sure you go this weekend
um if you like Disney and you want to
support Disney because you hate DeSantis
I guess I don't know go watch The
Gardens of the Galaxy I'm sure it's
going to be a great film
um I'm gonna go try to see it this
weekend at some point
um because I like the garden of the
Galaxy I think and they all the two have
been funny and and this is the first
Marvel film that's gonna drop a [__] in
it
that's crazy because they can probably
only get away with one [__] yeah so
that's the the story and if people for
the quick kind of like as we say goodbye
uh the quick story behind it is James
Gunn well here's the thing they always
especially on Guardians of the Galaxy
they're always trying to find ways to
throw like you know there's a lot of
improv that comes with these things and
there's definitely scenes that are
improvised uh that that actually make it
into the Final Cut
like the whole like why Gamora scene
that was by uh that was in uh uh
infinity War right
um that was by Drax right he's like oh
do you want better why gomor right it's
a whole anyway that was improvised as
well so these are moments that they have
that are like authentically improvised
that are great so how did they get to
putting the word yeah so in gardens the
Galaxy Chris Pratt and others always try
to find ways like oh we'll throw a swear
word in and never makes it in there's a
scene where they're on this like
alternative Earth and they're leaving
and they're getting into a car oh yeah
I've seen a preview of this uh and
they're having a car and he's like open
the door just push the button that's how
you get in the car right and he says
just he's like he's I forget his [__] or
[__] but he gets it in and Chris
Pratt was doing an interview and he's
like what happened was James Gunn was
like yeah I love that that's great like
totally improvised they found a way to
put it in and he's like I want to have
some Final Cut and then Kevin feige who
is the head of all of the M the Marvel
film Productions he was like ah do you
really want to be the guy who put the
first F-bomb in a Marvel movie and he's
like uh are you kidding me do you know
who I am of course I do [__] yes I do
and so n a yeah and also it's like if
there was any movie where like and
that's my swan song as I go off to DC
right I would [__] hope that you get
a [__] there yeah you want I I'm I'm
excited then to see this to be the first
so yeah you'll yeah so he you say he
says [__] you say [__] him at the movie
[__] him [__] him well everybody
be back tomorrow uh watch out this
afternoon on YouTube's on the tubes of
you don't forget to subscribe go to the
community tab you'll be able to vote for
bonehead of the week also on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you vote you decide
for Bona of the week tomorrow in the
second hour we will break down because
we definitely have the second hour We're
not gonna be able to go as long as we
did today yeah he's got a heart out so
tomorrow's second hour bone end of the
week we'll break it down also download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on apples apples
Spotify Google we're gonna play your
clip of your uh what was that
tomorrow but if you want to watch the
what was that show go to what was that
show.com or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez while you're on patreon don't
forget to visit my page at the Tony
Michaels just go to
patreon.commichaels also if you're a
prime user Amazon Prime account holder
you can tie your Prime account to Twitch
and if you give us that one free
subscription that you get with your
Prime account we get a couple bucks it
doesn't cost you a single nickel more to
give us some monetary support you guys
have been doing great over on Twitch
we've got a ton of support uh new
followers and a ton of new Prime
subscribers keep them coming
um that's awesome we appreciate all the
support and anyone uh anyone on my
patreon there'll be a new episode that
will be releasing early today it'll be
on the White House correspondence Center
so a lot of jokes a lot of roasting a
lot of laughing at Trump cool
Correspondence Dinner what was that go
check it out at patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez again while you're on patreon
check my page out at the Tony Michaels
patreon.com the Tony Michaels join us
tomorrow May the fourth be with you
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon